ich war mal wieder in den deutschen
youtube trends unterwegs und ich
wünschte ich wäre da nicht unterwegs
gewesen ich habe dort ein video entdeckt
namens 5000 euro sind zu wenig scharf
rohde ist der verwöhnte teenager der
welt davon hört sich an wie ein pokémon
kommen auf jeden fall handelt es nicht
bei dieser person namens saffron um
diesen teenager die grinst wie eine
banane wir schauen uns mal diesem
beitrag von taff an und versuchen nicht
zu kotzen sie ist er wohl verwöhntesten
teenager der welt überhaupt mit
luxuskarossen edelster designer kleidung
und schmuck in millionenhöhe schmuck in
millionenhöhe
ich habe nicht mal ein sport wohl ich
hab ein pflaster gerade wenn die sollte
man nicht verzogen
dann sollen sie das recht mir ist das
völlig egal an sich eine gute
einstellung also einfach so wie ich den
dreck zu scheren was andere über ihn
denken jetzt aber hat die einzige
tochter zweier schwerst reich
homosexuelle einen ganz besonderen
wunsch mal ganz kurz
ich könnt selbst nicht mehr den spiegel
schauen wenn ich meine adoptiveltern so
krass ausnutzen würde die leute werden
sich immer dem mund über uns zerreißen
natürlich ist interessiert mich nicht
wenn ich mir was leisten kann kauft wenn
du es nicht kannst dein pech ihr könnt
mich mal okay an sich wirklich wieder
eine vernünftige einstellung finde ich
also jeder sollte mit seinem geld
einkommen vermögen das anstellen dürfen
was er machen möchte wenn er sich ganz
viele luxus sachen kaufen möchte dann
ist es ihm überlassen aber jetzt zu
sagen herr jedem der es nicht passt ich
habe ich menschen sind ziemlich
abstoßend millionen surfern hat geladen
zum wohl schrägsten job casting seit es
leihmütter gibt denn die 18 jährige
wünscht sich ein baby und verzog gar
keine lust dafür selbst schwanger zu
werden
was ja es gibt tatsächlich dinge die man
sich nicht kaufen kann
und sie will jetzt wahrscheinlich sich
dann trotzdem ein baby von einer anderen
mutter abkaufen oder das vermutlich
meist gehasste rich kate der welt sucht
ernsthaft eine leihmutter und die sollte
so einiges verkraften
babyfläschchen empfiehlt in ein entweder
christian dior oder tommy hilfiger etwas
anderes kam bei unseren fünf kinder nie
in frage
walter ich glaube ein kind ist es
scheißegal ob da die oder gucci oder
tommy hilfiger draufsteht solange es
einfach die milch bekommt und auch beim
thema kind erwarten ist safran
kompromisslos der möchte schon einen von
louis vuitton oder von gucci und zwar
den besten den es gibt
ich kann mich nur wiederholen ich glaube
dem kind ist es scheißegal wurde rings
umher gefahren wird ich wünsche mir so
sehr ein baby dann kann ich es in die
sonne anpassen hat die seiner kinder
wecken spazieren fahren und hat eine
echte miniatur von mir selbst du hast
keine miniatur von mir selbst weil du
das kind nicht gepasst
du suchst du eine leihmutter und
schreibst du forderst sie die ohren
milchflaschen und louie vito kinderwagen
kaufen soll da frauen soll sie bei
pokemon bleiben
kontron genau wie für ihren bruder erst
dann gibt es stets nur das beste das
teuerste und das trotzig sste wir halten
fest sie hat noch einen bruder
wenn er genauso schlimm ist alter prost
mahlzeit das iphone bekommt ein
taschengeld von 5000 euro monatlich
damit darf sie sich kaufen was immer sie
brauchte oder möchte ihre anderen
ausgaben sind damit nicht abgedeckt wenn
sie sich also neue sneaker oder schuhe
kaufen möchte einen pulli oder eine
jacke dann hat sie ja noch ihre platin
kreditkarte
wow sie kriegt 5000 euro jeden monat um
sich halt die kleinigkeiten zu kaufen
die sie sich zu kaufen möchte aber wenn
sie neue sneaker will oder eine neue
jacke hat sie ja noch eine platin
kreditkarte kann ich dazu nicht sagen
aber finden sie 5000 euro nicht etwas zu
viel für einen teenager
meine eltern haben damals schon 30 euro
pro monat allzuviel angesehen ihre
schmucksammlung über eine million wird
allein diese zwei ringe kosten 400.000
euro
dieses pflaster 15 ringe da nicht
mithalten ich wohin jeder tourist meinen
körper nahm es zu dann wieder ab dann
noch die schwangerschaftsstreifen und
all das ich will einfach auf nichts
verzichten und man liegt weiterführen
wie bisher also soll sich eine
leihmutter um die geburt kümmern und ich
schon meinen körper
saffron mein name ist luca her ganz cool
wenn du mir deine adresse gibt habe ich
euch für die tür packen kann der preis
des mobils fast 200.000 euro und ja ich
liebe ihn drei freunde werden ihn auch
lieben und platz im vorne
die worte das ist eine familie die nur
darauf aus ist anderen zu zeigen hey
guck mal
wir haben es und wir müssen es auch
zeigen ich fand das damals so krass wo
dieser ich weiß nicht ob es der aldi
geschäftsführer war aber der sollte sage
ich mal entführt werden dann wollten die
lösegeld und die haben ihn nicht
entführen können weil er so ein ganz
bescheidenes büro hatten ganz
bescheidenen lebensstil aber die
das ist der abschaum
ich will dass deine freunde dich
beneiden
beneiden allein diese aussage
die kinder von denen werden nie wirklich
geld verdienen können und irgendwann
sind die eltern auch nicht mehr da oben
haben dann haben die alle kein geld mehr
und dann ende dann ist vorbei das ist es
muss irgendwann so sein und ich freue
mich auf wenn sowas eintrittsalter ich
liebe es einfach anderen eine freude zu
bereiten und meinen kindern all das zu
ermöglichen dass ich in meiner jugend
nicht hatte ersten wollte diesen war ich
habe das geld also hat er ihn bekommen
weil er es verdient eigentlich wirklich
wieder eine lobenswerte einstellung so
von wegen meine kindheit war schwer und
ich konnte viele sachen nicht haben die
ich mir als kind gewünscht habe und
möchte jetzt meinen kindern geben aber
dass es ein 200.000 euro ist er wie sein
muss darüber lässt sich ganz eindeutig
streiten bewahren ist der hammer gehabt
mich darum gute war schweineteuer aber
so ist man das nun mal so was macht er
ständig
ich glaube aber ganz ehrlich man muss
die kinder da auch ein bisschen in
schutz nehmen die kämen zeit nicht
anders der charakter eines kindes oder
eines menschen formt sich halt durch die
erziehung der eltern finde ich und wenn
die eltern einem vieles verbieten dann
ist man halt eher so ein mensch aber der
mann einfach nur sagt ja ich finde das
cool man bekommt es direkt an steigert
man sich natürlich als kind immer mehr
und will dann mehr und größere sachen
und dann ist man in so einer spirale
drin und kommt da nicht mehr raus und
verwundert es wenig dass die
jungfernfahrt in dem 550 ps geschoss
schon nach wenigen metern irgendwie
zwangsläufig die folgende frage aufwirft
was kriege ich als nächstes gewürzt sein
eigenes zuhause bekommen
unser
das einzige zu hause was ich den schenk
würde wenn eine hundehütte unser plan
ist surfen und diana anwesen zu schenken
wo ihr gemeinsam war uns nicht unter
einem dach jeder von euch hat dort sein
eigenes haus jeder sein eigenes haus
seine reaktionen sind nicht auch hermann
hay luca und sarah wir haben gedacht wir
kaufen euch beiden haus alter ich war
außer mir vor freude und dann gibt's
noch in den resten gerade in 200.000
euro auto geschenkt bekommen und bekommt
gerade noch ein haus geschenkt und sieht
so aus durch den den bonnern deinen kopf
ein xxl anwesen mit haupt- und
nebengebäuden soeben von barry erworben
für satte 2 millionen euro
ja wenn wir mal auf seine autofahrt
und sagen hey schenken zwei millionen
haus aber ganz ehrlich wie soll man denn
das noch toppen
du hast jetzt so ein großes anwesen du
könntest jedoch einen
hubschrauberlandeplatz könnten die
eigenen helikopter flotte zu legen
ganz im ernst mich wundert das
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr fehlt also
nur noch die perfekte leihmutter die
dann das wunschkind der 18-jährigen
austrägt sagte 150000 euro winken erlös
und scheinen sollte alle von ihnen den
job bekommen
150000 euro ihr müsst euch das einfach
mal überlegen das ist so real
da bekommen eine frau 150000 euro was
eine riesige summe geld ist dafür dass
sie schwanger wird aber dann ihr kind ab
gibt an eine reiche frau die nicht
schwanger werden will
sie kann wahrscheinlich schwanger werden
aber sie will einfach nicht weil sie
keinen bock hat abzunehmen danach wieder
ihr seid doch alle komplett am arsch sie
erinnert mich ein verzogenes kleines
kind das stets alles bekommen hat und
heute umso mehr möchte
das ist die erste sympathische person in
diesem beitrag wenn jemand mein kind
austragen würde wäre ich wahrscheinlich
genauso fordern insofern bestehe ich ihr
schon zu uns zu sagen was sie erwartet
was macht man nicht alles für viel geld
krass okay die beiden wollen das
wirklich machen ganz im ernst also wenn
ich eine frau wäre ich würde für kein
geld der welt ein kind bekommen dass
abgeben ich hätte mein kind extrem
verwöhnen
was immer er oder sie wollen wird das
wird auch geht solange sie nur so
dankbar sind wie ich seines
militärischen pullover handschuhe mützen
oder schals alles absolut
[Musik]